je me fais le défi d'en parler sans sans
pleurer parce qu'il aurait il aurait
détesté ça et la façon dont il m'a
inspiré dans ma vie c'est justement en
m'apprenant à rire de tout c'est un
homme qui a vraiment pas eu une vie
facile mais le travail est super jeune
dans les mines à alès et je n'ai jamais
entendu se plaindre on 88 ans ce qui est
quand même pas exactement mon cas j'ai
tendance un peu à me plaindre de tout et
n'importe quoi et lui il avait ce
courage incroyable et je crois qu'il m'a
vraiment appris moi à rire de tout en
fait surtout de man est prêt à me
prendre trop au sérieux
je sais pas c'est des personnalités
comme ça qui va une fois qu'elle
disparaisse on a l'impression que tous
deux un petit peu plus fans c'est qui
les personnes qui t'inspire
mon grand père m'a beaucoup inspiré m'a
appris beaucoup de choses il avait cette
faculté de rendre à tous les moments un
peu magique
par exemple pendant des années ils
cachaient des chocolats dans son journal
il me demandait d'aller chercher son
journal il ya toujours et je trouvais
toujours des chocolats et très longtemps
j'ai cru que c'était vraiment un
un espèce de tour de magie ou qu'ils
avaient une fait qu'il est qu'il ait
déposé là jusqu'à ce que je comprenne
ensuite que bah c'était elle et lui l'a
fait une des personnes qui m'a le plus
inspiré dans ma vie
on ne se souvient peut-être pas de moi
elle s'appelle madame murat je connais
même pas son prénom c'était ma prof de
français au collège et c'était
clairement une bonne fée pour moi parce
que l arrivée dans un moment de ma vie
où clairement bas j'avais pas beaucoup
de succès j'avais pas un grand succès
social quoi j'étais j'étais un peu moqué
est mis sur le côté et j'attendais ces
cours avec tellement d'impatience et
particulièrement les exercices de
d'écriture et je me souviens d'un jour
même ou alors que vraiment je n'étais
vraiment pas cool quoi dans ma classe
elle a dit devant tout le monde
souvenez vous de son nom parce qu'un
jour on pourra chasser libre ses livres
en librairie
ça a été une des premières personnes en
tout cas à à croire en moi à se dire que
ba peut-être y avait quelque chose à
faire de demas bizarreries et de mon
goût pour les mots parfois c'est des
petites des petites phrases des petits
encouragements qui arrive juste au bon
moment pour en fait finalement modifié
une trajectoire baudelaire et sans doute
l'écrivain qui m'a le plus inspiré
peut-être parce que c'est peut être que
j'ai découvert très jeune
mais j'ai vraiment le souvenir de
d'ouvrir les fleurs du mal pour la
première fois et de me dire mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ça fait un monde
parallèle en fait un livre je les lui ai
relu et comme c'est un recueil c'est
évidemment le genre de livre qu'on peut
ouvrir à n'importe quelle page si on a
une minute de son temps était vraiment
j'ai j'ai fait ça pendant des années
jusqu'à ce que au lycée il décide de
nous le faire étudier et alors ça ça a
été un drame pour moi j'ai trouvé ça
horrible en fait parce que j'étais
tellement attaché à baudelaire et aux
fleurs du mal que je n'avais pas du tout
envie de le partager avec les autres
élèves il ya une autre anecdote qui est
marrant c'est que quand il m'arrive des
trucs un peu dur par exemple quand je me
suis fait opérer des dents de sagesse
j'aimerais aussi des poèmes en fait et
j'ai tu les connais par coeur je les
connaissais par coeur mais je vous
croyais plus trop
j'ai plus de souvenirs que si j'avais
mille ans un gros meuble à tiroirs
encombré du bilan de verre de billets
doux de procès de romance avec de
lourches veut rouler dans des quittances
quelques jeux plus de secret que mon
triste cerveau je crois